live in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions
Blake and Courtney drop by hey guys how
are you hey that's going better than I
deserved welcome well so you're here to
do your debt free scream yes we are and
where do you live
we're out in Denver Colorado very cool
and how much debt have you paid off
eighty nine thousand very good and how
long did that take five long years
behind long years all right and range of
income during the five long years well
we started off making nothing I was
unemployed after the banking crisis had
some odds and ends ah
delivering pizza thank you for the idea
and at that point halfway through or so
we're making about thirty six thousand
mm-hmm and then started a business and
it's last year we made 72 with that yeah
zero to 72 that's like an infinite from
there yeah that's awesome way to go man
so what kind of debt was the eighty nine
thousand it was everything personal loan
student loans credit cards even some
money owed to the library well you
didn't leave anybody out baby we got
them all in there yeah I like that one
because it was easy to pay off yeah
that's the first one so five years ago
Courtney what happened we were sitting
at home unexpectedly um surprised but
greatest blessing her life had our
daughter and she was born with health
needs so we went from two incomes to one
income sitting in a 3,000 square foot
home with three cars and the three-car
garage doing normal and down to one
income daughter had her first eye
surgery and praise God she can see
perfectly she's just a miracle Wow and
he came home from work the week after
her first surgery and had been let go
from the bank oh great mm-hmm 2009 yeah
so from one income our two incomes to
one income to no incomes so we're
sitting around as listen to you on the
radio and I think that was a greatest
day of his life because money was never
easy for us I'm the spender I still love
to spend he's the wizard the saver
calculating where it's coming from and
cash envelopes saved our marriage really
I can shock with freedom now and not
worry about it and he doesn't have to
worry about sitting at home thinking
where's this
coming from and how are we paying for
this what's Courtney up to now yeah
really I hear yeah cool so then so the
radio you were listening on the radio
and you lose both jobs and then you go
we got to get serious about this so we
went to the library and checked out
Total Money Makeover read it in one
night found out our church was offering
the class signed up cool happiest day of
your life yeah absolutely yeah and then
halfway through class that our son was
born mm-hm and the class was a really
great blessing to us we were able to you
know start our plan and start getting
out of debt sold our house mm-hmm that
was the first step down to one car for
three of the five years mm-hmm
move somewhere smaller and many months
then yeah pretty early on in right after
he was born we moved and it was during
your class that I got life insurance as
weathered my wife and six months after
that I was diagnosed with cancer oh my
lord and FOMA so during the process of
the last five years we bought it three
times and was able to pay for it and
still get out of debt so it can be done
for those out there listening it's
possible that all three times so three
times you've had you've had it's come
back come back twice yes
the lymphoma yeah and the last time it's
been gone now for about a year and a
half so we're also cancer-free - yeah
that's a good news yeah raise god that's
awesome but I want to thank you for the
life insurance because without it we
would be really stressed out
yeah and that's something that I know
for her has really really helped get
through all this just knowing that if
and when this does come back you know
she's taken care of
so how old were you when you got the
insurance 30 Wow
there's no 30 year olds died everybody
knows that yeah but something in that
class woke you up enough you went and
got it huh yeah we're so grateful oh I'm
glad sander took care of you yeah so
you're set up because you're completely
uninsurable at least for a while until
you got a clean bill of health five
years out or so right yeah it's given us
the freedom to otherwise he'd be stuck
to a job for the benefits ethic
any life insurance and because he had
life insurance and a good amount of it
and was wise about how we were doing
with our finances he was able to start a
business and do what he loves then
double double his income right and while
you're fighting cancer this is
unbelievable only goes up from there and
I mean he's a warrior he will never say
it but he was working 60 hours a week
through chemo the last time I mean he is
just a fighter and so grateful for him
unbelievable you guys are amazing Oh God
really I mean between God and you saved
our marriage and just made our family so
much richer and we feel so blessed so
what kind of business did you open so we
do after-school enrichment programs for
elementary age we teach chess and Lego
classes and also performance magic oh
wow yeah a lot of fun get to work with
kids again I do a lot of the management
side of the business as far as hiring
coaches and so what you started the
business to make more money or how did
you end up starting a business I just
wanted to get back to working with kids
I had done that a long time before and
when we moved to Denver ten years ago I
just needed work I work with a bank and
so it's nice to get back to kids and
then I have a business partner that I
work with and he and I will be tending
your master series next week all right
forward to seeing you there and we're
really excited about coming but he he
has some experience in it as well and so
we've been working together and trying
to grow it and keep providing for us and
yeah it's fun being self-employed but
it's also not fun being self hi my
scariest crush and I say the editor of
Ebony magazine John Johnson used to say
that the entrepreneur is the only person
can go from sheer terror to sure an
exhilaration and back every 24 hours
it's the highs and the lows are amazing
they really are but it's in your case
it's it's giving you control of
everything and the ability to double
your income so it's just absolutely
incredible man you guys have you touched
every base I mean this is unbelievable
well I followed your advice we sold
everything anytime something would go
missing in the house we've downsized
three times the kids would blame me and
say mom you consignment sale or must
mom that's great well now that you've
fought through cancer job losses a
special needs situation and it's amazing
and $89,000 still gets paid off in five
years but you downsized and you chopped
and you you took the machete to some of
the lifestyle stuff didn't you
everything everything I went from
shopping at Macy's in Nordstrom to the
Salvation Army and my kids think that's
the greatest treasure hunt ever it is
was it worth it absolutely absolutely
how's it feel now to know any dad you're
standing feels I still don't
it hasn't settled in it's amazing the
spender and me went from debts going out
every month to now our that account is
the get living fund and we get to truly
get living and do things we haven't been
able to do for five years because going
to the grocery store was a risk for
germs so we're just so grateful to have
freedom financially and freedom just to
live and go and do what God calls us to
do absolutely absolutely Wow amazing
well I mean with and with good life
insurance in place and Blake with
Cortney she knows how to do this yeah I
mean so she can run this thing so I mean
if if something bad comes around then
you you know you that's got to give you
a lot of peace yeah just keep on with
the steps yeah I'd be lost without us we
can't go anywhere I wasn't getting up a
trip I'm just thinking you know that
with all you got it's been three times
you face this and and so that's a big
deal for him to know that you're taking
care of and that you now versus the
Cortney that we started with earlier in
the conversation you're I mean you're
you're on fire for this stuff and you
got control of everything so that's very
cool well I'm very proud of you guys wow
what fighters you are how fun very cool
what a victory story I love it and
cancer free baby that's what we're going
for right there I love it all right
Blake and Cortney and your kids names
are what Hadley and Nolan Hadley and
Nolan how old are they
seven and five seven and five perfect
all right eighty-nine thousand dollars
paid off in five years
man what a story it's
Blake Courtney Hadley and Nolan counted
down
let's hear a debt-free scream not down 3
2 1
oh my gosh how wonderful wow wow wow wow
that's how it's done folks
and fighters whoo this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show